hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play
ta-da'-da phobia escape from death ok
yamimash actually talked to me recently
it was like you gotta play this game so
I guess I got to play this game so I
don't know what it's about but it's made
by FPS creator which is still the same
engine that the first Slenderman shadows
maps were made from other than that I
don't really know there's a guy with an
axe over there in a lab coat so I'm
assuming you did something to do with
that oh hello oh hello alright do I have
any sort of light no I do not no no I
did not okay so some guy that I am is
breathing a little sporadically and we
seem to be in some sort of a hospital a
weird-ass hospital some sort because I
don't recall there are just medical beds
in medical bags alright sort of just
dropped in here no real objective oh
what's this I turned up my volume a bit
um there's something here a page a
picture was that it's a picture of a guy
can't pick it up or anything or not with
any button
okay yeah that's a doctor hahahaha and
he's standing in what looks like one of
these rooms I guess I'm supposed to
avoid him what was that hang on a minute
hang on let me get an idea of what's
going on before you start throwing
things at me haha Jesus [ __ ] you good
yeah right well I guess they're gonna
start throwing out things I mean anyway
alright that black that black is black
that bag is black I guess I'm just gonna
go in each room okay well anyway sign
over there
beware the darkness yeah no kidding hmm
beware the darkness pretty good advice
for you know life and all that it's
really dark I don't have any light like
just these spotlights do not create much
ambient lighting and it's kind of
concerning me nothing in here okay
unless there's something in the room I'm
not gonna spend a lot of time checking
in thought I saw purple another purple
bag recently but apparently I did not I
kind of concerned that that doctor guy
is gonna be flying at me anytime now
weird Hospital out too just like every
other room
I don't know yeah that looks ominous
okay here we go
let's read it oh oh that looks good
Elizabeth and blah blah blah Homer
Simpson ha ha ha you know not me
hello ok oh there's a body
please tell me that's still a dead body
completely dead dead body still dead
hmm hi head hey buddy
okay okay let's get out of here thank
you oh man
I don't like this it's like it's like a
it's like walking through or show or
walking through a haunted house you'd
see it Halloween time you just go room
by room and each thing's got something
different to scare you with you won't
survive - you won't survive either I
think is what you're looking for I
probably shouldn't criticize the doctor
that's trying to murder me on his
grammar
hi mr. doctorate got an axe the size of
my head perfectly sized for my head now
oddly sized but yeah your grammar sucks
okay it's just really dark I mean I can
barely see where I'm going when I'm
walking out of a room hmm well the
lights going out back there um I don't
know pretty low resolution game okay I'm
guessing that some of these rooms just
have nothing okay there's kind of a
vault door now I don't see any other
rooms okay let's go into the vault Oh
dad oh one more door wait hang on door
lock requires a key to open bull honky I
would like to get out of here now Oh
what Oh another set of halls all right
hello hi hey dead guys
okay just a bunch of naked dead guys
nothing out of the ordinary from my
horror game experienced naked dead games
is pretty much the norm if there were
clothes then I'd be concerned you know
see ha ha ha hi hey yamimash I don't
know who that is don't know who that is
but that's me why why you do this why
it's not fair
can't do that come on now
oh you son of a [ __ ] why am I in here
Oh yamimash is this why I needed to play
it are you duck why that picture - this
is creepy
not just like creepy creepy but stalker
creepy now why am I in this game oh boy
this game why why what why okay let's go
into the bathroom
cuz bathrooms are always good in horror
games look a floating book that's onna
there's a doctor who's killing everyone
in the hospital I don't know what
happened to the others but I heard
screaming Zin there blood everywhere I'm
scared about learning this room I think
he saw me who find this it's dangerous
get the hell out of here and save your
life before it's too late
press o to hide it Chris Q Oh ah what
the [ __ ] I just punched a JIT oh okay I
can punch things alright okay press o to
hide it oh is now working to hide it I
guess I got a book in front of me now
got a brain or a skull yeah bounce oh I
feel much safer now that I know I got my
epic ground you bounce bounce it yeah
okay I wish I knew how to hide but
apparently the O button does not work uh
uh okay so let's just carry on with my
notes here
best area whoo yeah okay more dead guys
there's a lot of dead guys here I don't
know what everyone's complaining about
it seems like the doctor has already
killed these people
or maybe the doctor didn't kill anyone
and on he's uh just come works in the
morgue
okay seems like now thing where's this
damn key that I've been told so much
about where's her room deck was that in
the back
run oh okay Bob I get to worry about I
don't ever say anything run run Oh
pounce pounce and run punch
oh [ __ ] you guy so that doctor was just
sitting there in the darkness waiting
for me I think I'm running I'm not going
very fast if I was running I would be
running much faster this is quite slow
for me why would he want to kill me he's
got my pictures all over the walls Jesus
how long is this hallway okay gotta be
coming up on the left here huh hang a
left go down to third get it on I gotta
kill you bet I got okay punch it like
out okay I have a key oh maybe I didn't
pick it up cuz I got this friggin book
in my face yes
okay so um I'm pretty sure I picked up a
key and all that and I don't see where
the doctor is
where the doctor go oh he's right down
here right [ __ ] in front of me all
right um I don't know what to do to show
me good I are dead well what the hell
with that
what I'm gonna try that again and I'm
gonna I'm gonna try that again I'm gonna
go straight ignore everything else cuz
nothing else is needed besides that key
I'm gonna try to pick up I think me
having the baton up the game crashed
well passin vinegar or hang on we try
this again cuz I want to see the ending
cuz obviously this guy I refreshed in
three two one
so obviously this guy made it for um
let's players not just me I mean I was
four yamimash and those other two guys
as well so I got it I gotta see it to
the end pilots just sprint fastest I
can't ignoring everything nothing
matters I've already seen it I've seen
your horror show of nightmares I'm going
to carry on so this doctor is is sitting
in the corner waiting for me and I need
to get the hell out of here while I'm
walking I'll come in this is not a bad
game this is not a bad way to design a
game I mean there are obviously things
you could do to be more objective wise
but the story is there it exists it's
not doesn't have a lot of substance but
there is a story to this game given that
you're in a hospital and you're trapped
in a doctor who's obviously psychotic
and murderous and it's trying to play
games like jigsaw style games with his
patients or something like that or I
don't know how I even got him in here
but it's kind of diabolical in a lot of
ways but it's not a bad game like just
uh it's a series of set pieces that's
what it is it's not exactly an immersive
experience is not for replayability but
for a one-time show it's pretty freakin
creepy so not bad I I definitely
appreciate
hmm still kind of creepy and thanks for
putting me in the game bottle hey Donna
why adjust that picture that's picture
from a while ago I don't even remember
really what those for okay so we just
got to go in here and where is it where
as it were as it were as it were as it
were
ah it's supposed to be here Oh see
anything
there's nothing here oh where is it give
me give me give me give me give me give
me I picked up okay go go go go
Holly balls maybe it was always with the
lineup after I trigger some things in
the cave okay I'm running I'm running as
fast as I can I don't think I can pounce
anymore but at least I can run Jesus I
didn't even know like after a while this
chase gets a little less dramatic
considering it's just like I'm running
there's no real tension like I can't
tell that he's behind me I'm supposed to
discern that he is right by me but I'm
going awfully slow so this could be
improved
all right and then we go down the stairs
and then we go through the door door
unlocked doors off yes I picked up a key
I picked up the key I don't know what's
going on here I'm guessing that must
just be bugged or something oh damn it I
would really love I really love to read
the credits or something like that but
apparently I don't know what's going on
hmm
I don't know if there's something I'm
doing wrong man let's go meet the doctor
again hey doctor I've got a back pain in
my neck you got anything extended all
right so I are dead so anyway um I wish
I could to sing the ending I don't know
what I did wrong so I don't know but
either way cheese please productions
great job I wouldn't read the credits if
I could have but either way great job
thanks for making it thanks for putting
me in the game I'm glad you think highly
of me so thank you everybody else for
watching click the annotation for more
videos that I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video bye-bye
nope